père car le président va prendre trois
jours de vacances tout ça et peut-être
complètement normal ou alors ça ne l'est
pas dans l'opposition on trouvait que
peut-être le président devrait être plus
présent ça énerve beaucoup gabriela
talent c'est un nouveau secrétaire
d'état il est chargé de la jeunesse et
l'a dit ce matin sur france info
voilà franchement je vous avoue que
quand je vois ce débat depuis hier sur
le break de trois jours du président de
la république je me dis franchement on
est un peu chez les dingues n'a vu j'ai
vu une intervention de christian jacob
qui est quand même président du premier
groupe d'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale les républicains qui parlait
de ça pendant 20 secondes
il avait autre chose à dire sur les
réformes qu'on en fait porter aux
nettement je trouve ça totalement
or seuls alors peut-être que c'est hors
sol ou peut-être que le président n'a
public a tellement laissé entendre qu'il
était exceptionnel qui dormaient que
quelque sorte par nuit
et que du coup on est presque surpris de
le voir ben il ya besoin de repos que la
chartier moi je trouve que ça dansait
tavaux de fatigue en fait en quelque
sorte c'est une façon de reconnaître
qu'il a été marqué par une séquence
extrêmement pénible pour lui depuis la
rentrée
de la même façon ça m'a fait penser à
son allocution à l'occasion du
remaniement où il a reconnu que ces
expressions pouvait être mal perçu que
son comportement vis-à-vis des élus
locaux étaient pas non plus celui qu'il
fallait donc il a rectifié le tir
donc sans faire de commentaire de
parallélisme mitterrandien un peu
malvenu je trouve que on voit là une
sorte de force tranquille en fait parce
que on sait bien qu'il faut être fort
pour pour admettre ses failles ses
faiblesses et là en fait il le fait et
sur le fond il là je trouve qu'il a
plutôt raison de ralentir le rythme
parce que la frénésie n'est jamais bonne
conseillère
et en plus vu ce qui s'annonce avec la
campagne des européennes aussi important
de conseil et on interne le monde des
coq à sa politique fixée à fiscale je
pense que c'est plutôt justifié légitime
est plutôt malin
les spectateurs on a un peu oublié il
faisait des breaks comme ça aussi
françois hollande où vous savez françois
hollande il a vécu un été 2012 à plus ou
moins épouvantable il a pris quelques
jours de vacances et il s'est fait très
fortement critiqué pour ses vacances
donc résultat il n'a plus pris aucune
vacance pendant tout le reste du
quinquennat
moi je me souviens quand je suis arrivé
à l'elysée c'était un jeudi le vendredi
soir j'allais le voir dire à lundi m'a
dit à demain le samedi soir j'allais le
voir pour lui dire à lundi m'a dit à
demain ne s'est pas arrêté pendant trois
ans il ne s'est jamais plaint je ne m'en
suis jamais plaint pourquoi parce que
quand on est au service de la france on
au service des français
on donne son temps 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 pendant l'intégralité de son
mandat personne n'avait forcer ni
nicolas sarkozy ni françois hollande ni
emmanuel macron à postuler à l'élection
présidentielle et une fois qu'ils y sont
ils doivent le faire à fond jusqu'au
bout
évidemment comme dans un marathon il
faut savoir ménager ses forces et on a
bien le droit de se reposer même de
dormir de temps en temps mais je trouve
qu'ils veulent macro et aussi un peu
puni par là où il a péché quelle mise en
scène nous avons eu droit au président
qui ne dort jamais ça te force à reculer
qui n'a pas vu qui peut se déployer
partout sur le globe en habitant et puis
on a eu aussi le droit des images des
vacances à des images du week-end avant
la campagne et c'est donc faux pas ce
faux pas s'étonner aujourd'hui qu'on
s'intéresse à son break
parce que lui même et son entourage ont
mis en scène de façon perpétuelle le
président sportif qui fait du vélo qui
fait du foot etc
donc il est puni par là où il a péché
bon et bien comme la température baisse
ça tombe bien puisque le voilà habillé
pour les verts partagent pas ce point de
vue donc je pense que le podium la
république qui prennent trois jours et
que ça fasse l'objet d'un de débats
nombreux depuis l annonce de ces de ces
trois jours me semble grotesque mais
vraiment grotesque pourquoi parceque il
fait effectivement un travail de
président avec un style original
moi j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer sur
ce sujet mais il dirige la france comme
on dirige une entreprise plus que comme
un homme politique et donc il est dans
une espèce d'obsession du résultat de la
réforme du travail
et effectivement il nous a fait savoir
qu'ils bossaient 21h sur 24 et que
évidemment la presse avide de sensations
fortes et ravi lorsque sur un
comportement une attitude une forme de
2,2 d'expression personnelle qui est
orthogonale par rapport à cette image de
premier classe parfait le chef
d'entreprise qui gouverne la france
absolument comme si c'était une
multinationale
tout cela la presse lui tombe dessus je
trouve ça franchement hors de propos bon
il a un coup de fatigue c'est vrai que
la rentrée a pas été facile
il s'est tapé de la sphère benalla qui
était avant la rentrée
jusqu'à la démission de colons en
passant par du lot c'est impartial de
l'eau effectivement les problèmes autour
de l'apli qualité parfois il a un
travail devenant la république et il est
effectivement fatigue et j'imagine de
l'ensemble de ce qu'il a à faire mais ce
que je crois et qui n'était pas tout à
fait le cas ses prédécesseurs c'est
qu'il a pris la pleine mesure du
quinquennat lui et que matignon et à
l'elysée une bonne fois pour toutes
voilà et donc et il le fait il dirige ce
pays comme un premier ministre plus
comme un pédant de la république
il a deux boulots c'est con si l'argent
on disait ça de sarkozy s est sarkozy
mais je trouve que manuel macro pousse
la logique encore un cran plus loin
edouard philippe se planquent si je puis
dire un petit peu moins
que françois fillon va vous donner la
parole
je voulais vivre juste pardon des
témoignages d'internautes cij qui nous
disent qu est ce qui est très juste ce
ne sont pas ces vacances qui sont
étonnantes
mais le fait que ça n'avait pas l'air
anticipé et c'est vrai qu'au début on a
même dit que le conseil des ministres
été avancée à mardi parce que le
président m'a public avait un engagement
officiel ensuite anti mac nous dit je
pense qu'il nous fait une grosse déprime
et arcuset nous dit il peut avoir besoin
de se reposer mais il peut le faire avec
plus de discrétion
même si c'est vrai qu objectivement
c'est plus nous les médias qui parlent
donc ses vacances que vous que lui qui
les a annoncé frédéric dabi est ce que
vous pensez que les français vous
reprochez à macro de partir en vacances
comme il l'avait reproché à françois
hollande à l'été de malheureuse comme le
rappelait ne vous laisse pas je pense
lui reprocher il ya des critiques
beaucoup plus compliqué pour lui en
termes la justice de sa politique en
termes de distance par rapport aux
préoccupations des français en terme de
résultats notamment sur le pouvoir
d'achat
je n'en sais un petit peu ce gaz candeur
à 10 en 2012 françois hollande il ya eu
quelques propos sur ses vacances c'est
moins ses vacances qu'ils ont été
empochés que le sentiment qu'ils avaient
pas pris la mesure de la fonction
notamment au moment du plan de
licenciements annoncés pour le tsa et
notamment la surprise du choc fiscal
annoncé le 9 septembre 2012 sur tf1 ou
voilà les français avaient été
complètement décontenancé que ce n'était
pas dans sa campagne présidentielle
maintenant je vais à la raison on est
quand même merci je pense qu'on est
quand même sur une construction
médiatique
rappelez vous après le 14 juillet 2009
comme nicolas sarkozy avait fait un
petit malaise après avoue thing il y
avait aussi tout un emballement
médiatique sûr il y avait épuisé le
président super héros donc je pense que
on n'est pas sur des sujets qui vont
impacter l'opinion publique il paraît
qu'il part en vacances en normandie vous
avez des informations en week-end en
week-end par dont fabrice hilton ah oui
quand-même moi les vacances et les
week-ends qui commencent le mercredi
soir à excuser moi il fait le pont au
figaro ce pas comme ça
le prix fait le banc il fait le point à
vrai dire nous aussi pour